la resolución de la Corte Suprema que es
conocimos durante esta jornada marca un
antes y un después en causas de Derechos
Humanos aquí en chile se condenó a 59 ex
agentes de la dictadura todos
integrantes de la dirección de
inteligencia nacional ladina una de las
organizaciones de represión de la
dictadura de Augusto pinochet son
condenados por la muerte de 16 personas
esto en el marco de la investigación de
la denominada operación Colombo que fue
un operativo un montaje que desarrolló
la dictadura para hacer pasar la muerte
de opositores a ella como Víctimas de
enfrentamientos y de operativos también
fuera de las fronteras chilenas sin
embargo todos estaban detenidos en
centros de reclusión clandestina en
nuestro país en donde estaban siendo
torturados años atrás en esta causa
todos los imputados habían sido
absueltos así que con esta resolución
judicial se ratifica su culpabilidad y
responsabilidad en estos hechos
revocándose esta decisión de años atrás
de la corte de apelaciones
específicamente los abogados de Derechos
Humanos han dicho que esta definición de
la corte de Suprema en Chile el máximo
tribunal del país marca un antes y un
después específicamente por su
relevancia entre otras cosas porque este
año el 2023 se cumplen 50 años del golpe
de estado en Chile